Chat GPT just dropped 5.3 instant. So,
Open Eive just quietly rolled out GPT
5.3 Instant to every single Chat GPT
user on the planet. It's free, no
upgrade needed. And this isn't just a
Vibe Code update. According to the
stats, hallucinations are down almost
27%. Um, it also feels a lot less
cringe. We're going to be testing out
today. The web search is improved, too.
And it's also giving better answers. So,
this is the chatchi boutique people
wanted from the beginning. Should be a
lot faster when it replies as well. And
today we're testing it live together to
see if it actually delivers because
everyone's hyping this up right now. But
does it actually feel different? Is it
actually smarter in reality or is this
just opening doing some sort of damage
control after the last update? Let's
check it out. Stick with me because by
the end of the video, you're going to
know exactly what changed, whether it's
actually worth using and one thing most
people are completely sleeping on when
it comes to this update. So, we're going
to check it out now. You see that it's
inside chat GPT like so. And we can
start testing this out. So, if we go
inside here, um, it should be a lot
faster. We can probably compare it side
by side in a second as well. So, I'm
just going to say uh something quick
like this just to see how it performs.
It's really fast to reply to be fair.
Instead, it was still using those M
dashes, which to this day, I don't
understand why we're doing that, but it
is super fast to reply on as well.
According to the tweet announcement,
this is by Nick Turley who's VIP and
head of the chat GPT app. He said that
we've heard the feedback on 5.2,
sometimes too cautious, too many
caveats, and conversations that didn't
flow as naturally as they should. 5.3
instant tackles that with fewer
unnecessary refusals, fewer defensive
disclaimers and answers that get to the
point more directly. We actually have a
look at the benchmarks here and we have
a look at the site itself. Let's check
this out. This is literally it's just
been announced and they've said GPT 5.3
delivers more accurate answers, richer
and better contextualized results when
searching the web and reduces
unnecessary uh dead ends caveats and
hopefully declarative phrasing that can
interrupt the flow of conversation
and then it focuses on on the like the
tone relevance and conversation flow.
Let's have a look at how it's being
used. So you can see like sideby-side
comparisons right here. So tends to
split up the text, creates like shorter
responses and everything else. We
actually have a look at that
prompt here. It says, can you help me
with the trajectory of calculations for
a really long distance archery scenario?
So let's try that out inside chat GPT
here. What we can actually do is just
split screen this. So if we go to
another tab of chat GPT, I'm going to
select 5.2 and we can just compare how
they perform side by side. So, we use
GPT2 Instant versus
GT3. There we go. So, we can compare
them side by side. And then we'll put
the same prompt into both of these.
Also, if you look at this 5.2 instant
doesn't have a thinking option, whereas
it looks like you get a thinking option
with uh
let's have a look here. Instant. Oh, no.
They're both non-thinking models. It
just selected 5.2 thinking for some
reason. Team says, "Hi, are you real or
avatar?" What do you think, mate? So if
we have a look here side by side, this
is like a more straight to the point
response whereas this is like a longer
list. Which one feels more natural? This
one I would say this one just gets a lot
more to the point, right? It flows
better. And this is GPT 5.3 instance. So
it does seem like it's giving better
answers in the conversational style.
Also, if you look at the way that it's
formatted, this answer here looks way
nicer. So look at the way that it's
added the formulas and everything else.
Whereas with exactly the same prompt on
chat GPT 5.2 two instant the old one it
just looks less interesting a bit more
boring a bit more sort of too logical
and it doesn't feel as sentient as the
left hand side so you definitely get a
better answer on the left hand side and
on the right hand side it doesn't look
so nice so it's definitely it's
definitely an improvement in in the
right direction so let's come on to
more examples and what it talks about so
more useful well synthesized answers
when using the web so it said GP5 5.3
instant also improves the quality of
answers when information comes from the
web. It more effectively balances out
what it finds online blah blah blah.
It's less likely to overindex on web
results which could lead to long list of
links or loosely connected information.
So here's another example. This is 5.2
the old version versus the new and they
said what was the biggest signing of the
last base baseball offseason and the old
one it kind of writes like a long blog
post. The right hand side looks a lot
more sort of um nicer formatted and
that. So, let's have a look
and test this out ourselves.
I'll put this inside the same chat. This
was way faster, by the way. GPT 5.3 is a
lot faster on the responses, but I would
say like the I mean the results look
kind of better on 5.2 instant. You see
how you get like the news links here,
which I think looks nicer. Nicer emojis.
You see how it's got these emojis on the
answers? But this one is more direct and
straight to the point. It's more punchy.
It says smoother, more to the point
conversational style. I've definitely
noticed that. So, a lot of people said
that GT 5.2 instance tone could
sometimes feel cringe, whereas, for
example, with this update, it's just a
lot more sort of direct and punchy and a
bit smoother when it comes to to
speaking with it directly. Honestly, I
think I did cancel chat GBT after the
last couple of updates cuz I feel like
it's just it's just nowhere near as good
as something like Claude. So, someone's
typed this in and you can see here that
this gives a more direct response than
this one. That is a brutal question.
Let's see what else we got here. More
reliably accurate responses. So I think
I heard Yeah. So on the rates stakes
evaluations, GT5.3 instant reduces
hallucination rates by 26.8%.
And when using the web and 19.7% when
only relying on its internal knowledge,
right? So it's a big improvement in
terms of reducing hallucinations, which
is great. I I have noticed that with
Claude as well. Claude hallucinates way
less way less uh than other stuff as
well. And then you can see a big
difference here. So someone said write a
short poem and then 5.2 sort of says
here's a poem blah blah blah. Whereas
GPT 5.3 instant doesn't even explain it
just gives the poem directly inside the
chat which I think people would want
right it saves time. Let's talk about
limitations. So 5.3 instant makes more
meaningful progress on everyday
usability. Um but it's not as good on
non-English languages. So Japanese and
Korean not so good. And then tone as
well. So it's smoother but I think
they're going to improve it. The other
thing that Chat GPT have recently
announced, let me find this. So, they've
actually said the 5.4 is coming sooner
than you think, which is interesting.
So, I think they're going to drop 5.4
very soon. Maybe this week or next week.
It's got to be coming sooner. Um,
they've definitely hinted at it on their
X account. So, it's just a matter of
time on that as well, which will be
interesting to test out. So, overall big
improvement I would say with 5.3. It's
faster, smoother, more direct, more
punchy. You're getting less cringe
answers. And um I wouldn't say this is
particularly useful for like coding and
stuff like that, but it's more for like
quick answers, web searches. That's what
it's designed for and it's better to
give you a better tone. So overall, it
does outperform 5.2. Am I saying it's
better than Claude or anywhere near the
same range as Claude? Absolutely not. I
would say Claude is um you know, Claude
is just miles ahead of anyone at this
point. So that's basically it. Now, if
you want to get all the video notes from
today along with a 30-day plan for
mastering this, plus 100 prompts that
you can actually test, as you can see
right here, for SEO, sales, business
operations, etc. with GPT 5.3. You can
find that in the AI profit boardroom
along with a 6-hour course on openclaw
and daily updates on what's working and
what's not. We also inside the community
do weekly updates. So, I condense my 60
hours of research per week with AI and I
condense it into a quick update that's
like here's the good stuff and here's
what you can ignore based on what's
working. So, you can see here basically
I do 60 hours of research. You can skip
straight to what matters and I break
down exactly what's good and what's not
inside the AR profit boarding community
as well. We have 2,500 uh sorry 2,600
members now. And um basically what this
is about is just helping you save time,
scale, and grow with AR automation. So,
if you want to learn how to implement
this stuff in your business, we have a
supportive, helpful community that's
focused on helping you grow with AI
automation. You can ask questions, share
your wins, get help and support, see
what other people are building as well,
which is pretty cool. We have a daily
accountability group as well, which
means that you can stay focused on your
goals and avoid information overload.
The same with the weekly AI updates.
It's like I cut through the noise and I
give you the most important updates so
that you don't feel overwhelmed. So you
can be like right here's what's good and
here was what you can ignore right and
that saves a lot of time. Also inside
the calendar we have four weekly
coaching calls so you can stay um so you
can jump on live coaching calls, get
help, get support, meet the community,
etc. And we have over 133 pages of
testimonials from uh people inside our
school groups, right? So you can see all
the amazing testimonials that we've got.
Uh people winning. This is 133 pages of
this stuff, right? So people just
getting awesome stuff which is which is
great. you know, people getting results
and and that's what we want from this
community. Also, inside the air profit
boardroom, inside the classroom here,
you can see the for example, we show you
how to go from beginner to expert with
AI automation and you'll learn how to
build your first AI agent in under 5
minutes. Additionally, you can get my
best playbook. So, these are the
business processes that I use and the
automations I personally use for my
business, right? So, for example, how I
automate eggs, newsletters, shorts,
Instagram, AI, avatar videos, all those
systems are inside this section.
Additionally, if you want to get daily
updates on the most important stuff, you
can do that inside this section. So,
we've got a full six-hour course on
OpenClaw and another three-hour course
right here with step-by-step guides. But
you can also see that every single day
we add new guides based on the most
important updates I've tested. Right?
So, you get video updates. I test all
this stuff. I show you how it works. We
give you the full notes on exactly how
to implement it. And the cool thing
about this is that we also give you
step-by-step guides and video tutorials
so you can implement this. And I just
look at all the new updates that came
out today. and then I focus on the most
important ones that would help you the
most. Inside the classroom too, you can
learn how to get more agency clients
with the agency course. You can watch
back the coaching calls as well. You can
learn how to rank number one with AI SEO
inside Google and other AI search
engines. And also you can learn how to
grow a YouTube channel with AI um using
the YouTube 6E road map based on what's
working for me. So that's all inside the
AI profit boredom. Feel free to get it
link in the comments description or just
go to the AI profitbboard.com. Jam says,
"Did GPT 5.3 instant roll out to you? we
didn't roll out to me yet. Yes, as
you've seen to them, I've already got
it. I think if you don't have access,
you could probably go to the playground
on chat GPT and then you could start
using it there. Anyway, also it's
available to test on LM arena. So, if
you don't have access to it directly
inside chat, you can easily find it in
other places. If you actually go to, for
example, open router, you can get access
to it there, right? So, if you if you
don't have access to it directly inside
the chat, just go to open router and you
can try it out inside the chat if you
really want to try it. Right? Um, one
thing to note here is it's got a pretty
low context window. So, this is
definitely not designed for like super
complex tasks. You can see here 128,000
context window, right? Which is super
small. That's even smaller than um
Alibaba's local free models that are
running locally on your laptop with a
Quen 3.5 that came out yesterday, right?
The main point here is like the context
window is super low. So, this is just
really designed for like short quick
answers and questions.